what's up believe nation today I could
really use your help with my book so
today's video is a little different in
my usual book video today I want to ask
you for your help and let you know how
you can get involved in helping me mark
in the book and spreading awareness for
what we're doing it's something that my
publisher is asked me to do we're going
to be lining up interviews for me in
December and close to the book launch
date which is december six and i was
hoping you guys could help me out as
well what i'm basically looking for are
our people have a youtube channel email
list social media following obviously if
you would like to purchase the book
that's amazing if you want to do a bulk
order to gift out to your clients and
friends that's awesome too but apart
from that if you have an email list or
youtube channel or social media
following or you know somebody or the
somebody you look up to that you consume
in a regular basis who has a show a
podcast a channel is on traditional
media whatever you think if you have any
kind of connection in and you think that
I would be a good fit I would love the
opportunity to have a conversation and
get involved to help spread the message
we're aiming for around december early
december to be the release but a lot of
times these interviews happen before and
so that's why i'm asking you guys now I
wanted to give you a little bit more
context on the book what it's all about
what the benefits are to help you guys
have a greater understanding it's called
your one word because it's really book
about self-awareness it's about finding
what it is that you stand for so that
you can start to live a life and a
business create a company create a
movement on purpose a lot of people
don't really know what they stand for
don't run their business by a set a rule
or principle and so it's harder for them
to make decisions and it's harder for
people to want to go out and talk about
your business and spread your message
for you and so it highlights how I for
my business around believe instead of
the mess that I had before how it's
really helped me and my company has
helped spread my message how it's helped
guide the content my hiring decisions
everything around my business and helps
you do the same thing with yours I
wanted to share an example from one of
the stories in the book where there's
a florist who was a fan of mine and
connected with me and wanted help
selling flowers and the flower industry
is brutal it's super price competitive
there's lots of competition a lot of the
established buyers and vendors and
partners have already made partnerships
with florists it's an extremely you know
margin sensitive everybody's movement on
line two and you're being cut from
online distribution and as soon as the
economy goes down one of the first
things that gets cut is flowers it's a
luxury item so people are going to buy
it as much so who wants to be in the
flower business well my fan did my
subscriber did so I wanted to help him
and I asked him why are you in the
flower business and he said the flowers
make him calm and that his one word was
calm and so now that's a differentiating
factor for him for him to have success
it's going to be building his business
around calm and so what he wants to do
is now not just be another flower shop
of be the calm shop so everything now
changes from the flowers that he stocks
should make people feel calm when I walk
in even the outside the store should
make me feel calm the music should
become the displaying layouts should
make me feel calm the staff that greet
me and talk to me should make me feel
common at ease it should be a haven that
people want to go to because they want
to feel calm and yes they're going to
buy some flowers as well and so now if
your competitor cuts their price by one
percent you're not going to lose all
your customers because they're coming
for you for something much more powerful
than just buying flowers and so applying
that strategy to your business one helps
you differentiate people now know what
you are all about people will spread the
message for you you're making it easy to
say why you're so different compared to
everybody else and you're also more
likely to attract better clients and
better because they feel the same way
that you do you want people to come in
who want to feel calm and so they'll be
attracted by that message some people
say calm that's stupid you know I just
want some flowers those guys will never
be your best customers never ever ever
ever they'll be the ones who hang on
price to be the ones who never come back
they'll you guys just won't get along
great let them self eliminate you want
to create a magnet to attract
like-minded people to your business
customers supplier
partners investors media because you now
have a message and so that's what I want
you guys to find for your business
that's what the book helps you do the
first section is all about helping you
identify what your one where it is some
people find it really quickly some
people just instinctively know some
people need more time in coaching and
practice and exercises to go through for
me I needed more time I didn't know
believe was my thing right away I
thought it was too big too bold Who am I
to be the believe guy when so many other
people have used it all of these kind of
limiting thoughts so some people find it
super quick and some people need the
exercises and practice to go through to
find what it is that they stand for and
then section 2 goes into the marketing
how to create a movement how to create a
campaign how to get people talking about
you how to start getting customers that
come to your business and spread the
message for you and in section 3 is how
to build a company around it how to hire
how to do operations how to pick
suppliers how to get investors all on
board using your one word strategy it
chronicles my journey through the
process and it also chronicles
businesses at various stages from
roberto blake who made a
fifty-thousand-dollar full time income
for himself around his one word to a
five hundred thousand dollar business to
a million-dollar business 25 million
dollar business to you know hundreds of
million dollar business and so every
step along the way it shows how they
apply their one word to their business
no matter what stage your eye right now
there's people that you can model and
learn from so that's what the book is
all about it's not just a money grab for
me you know i'm not making really money
from this right the money goes to the
publisher it's it's something that i've
poured a ton of love and effort into i
think there's a lot of people on YouTube
who launched a book and it's just
another way to get their brand out and
it's not really you know the ghost wrote
it with somebody else that's not really
something there you know insanely proud
of this is something that I want to live
on if you follow the exercises in this
book it's life-changing it's had such an
impact on me and the people that I've
walked through it then I just want to
get it into your hands I want to see it
touch millions of people's lives that's
what it's all about is why I'm so
passionate about it and any help that
you guys think that you can provide in
terms of obviously buying copies and
buying it for your friends and helping
spread the message but also if you have
mr. social media list or platform
anywhere or these people that you look
up to who's podcast you listen to and
think it might be a good guess for let
me know set me up with introductions I'm
going to be doing a big kind of media
blitz social media blitz and I would
really sincerely love your help your
support to be able to reach those people
and help spread the one word message
because i think it is truly important
and will have a big impact so thank you
let me know in the comments below if if
you can help or support shoot me an
email otherwise i really appreciate it
guys thank you so what you're watching
next week we'll be back to a regular
evans book video continue to believe in
the meantime or whatever your one where
it is and I'll see you soon